hey hey Mon it's my fault oh and welcome
to the Oder flows market analysis for
Thursday August 31st 2017 and you know
it's month end we ended up getting a
nice rally in the SPS basically over the
last hour two hours of the session and
closed up near the highs
now the effects of Hurricane Harvey are
finally being felt in the commodities
market oil was up about a buck and back
over 47 dollars as gasoline futures
surged 8% on the day to a buck 77 so
Gold's dollar showed a little change the
gold is showing some additional life it
was up about 15 bucks to 1325 so let's
jump into the market but first a brief
disclaimer this presentation is for
educational and informational purposes
only should not be considered a
solicitation to buy or sell a futures
contract or make it any other type of
investment decision future strain
contentions tantra risk and is not for
every investor an investor could
potentially lose all or more than the
initial investment risk couple is money
that could be lost without jeopardizing
one's financial security or lifestyle
only risk capital should be used for
trading in a way those with sufficient
risk capital should consider trading
past performance is not necessarily
indicative of future results okay so
that said the tools used in this
presentation are the order flows trader
which is the volume footprint chart and
Delta scalper which is an additional
order flow tool to read the Delta and
just make your trading with order flow a
bit easier rather you know it's what it
does is it basically analyzes the Delta
for you and gives you buy and sell
signals but again you should take it all
in context of the market you know don't
miss me when people have built trading
systems right around the Delta scalper
but you know you should always take
everything in context of the market you
know when you're buying try to buy near
lows and selling your highs rather than
just taking everything finally I think
that makes for a better trading overall
so first we'll talk about the e-mini
like I said you know a manís we put in a
nice rally later in the session
but for the morning we're pretty much
kind of quiet and I think that was to be
expected you know you got the non-farm
payroll numbers tomorrow and again it
was month end and you know it on month
end you tend to get you 10
get some nice nice moves late in the
session you know as as you seen
portfolio balancing coming in and you
know tomorrow Monday you probably see
some new positions being added and I
personally I think the market tomorrow
Friday will be an update but we'll see
you know historically non-farm payroll
days are have a higher percentage of
closing higher on the date and they do
lower well you know what you know I
talked about today is this we'll start
here with the forum range emini chart
and you know 8:45 this morning you know
we rally started rallying up after the
cash open into the new highs and then
you got your divergence here on the high
right here negative Delta 784 then you
know you got one green bar then comes
right back with the stack selling
imbalance you know three one nine four
seven nine fifteen twenty seven which is
bearish and it's you know like I just
said take things in context of the
market and it's right up here right off
the hi it's a tick off the high two
ticks off the high that you're selling
them stacks on the balance starts
happening and then the next part you got
the bearish ratio again
there's also bearish so you're getting a
few signals already you know you got
your divergence you got price rejecter
you got stacked and balanced if you have
bearish ratio and you know I'll say I
was looking for this market to sell off
I was looking forward to you know
sell-off down around 61 you know all
right now we're trading 65 I was looking
for a quick move down to 61 and what
happens so you got the one bar here next
bar what do you get you got some
supportive bine in here three one five
five to 703 you know you got it's not a
bullish ratio it's just your average you
know number and your regular order flow
occurring
you know markets transacting is doing
what it's doing and then we start
rallying back up so the third bar you're
up in back up inside you're stacked in
balance zone now that's not a good sign
right when you have a stacked imbalance
what you want is the market to move and
you want it to move quickly you don't
want it to sell off you know the next
couple bars rally back up there and then
expect to sell off I mean can it happen
yeah it can happen but the further you
get away from the stacked imbalance the
effectiveness of it lessens right and it
should be happening
you know if the selling is really
legitimate strong selling that's gonna
move the market you know you should be
seeing you got a sign here with the
bearish ratio you got one imbalance but
in this bar you should also see some
aggressive Sally not positive Delta not
the market starting to move back up and
by the fourth bar you're still in that
stack imbalance you put in some decent
volume in here now what you should be
looking for when you come back up into
the stack imbalances selling imbalances
again because you had the selling of
balance here early now you're back up in
here where are the sellers are they
reappearing no instead you're seeing in
support of buying
24:39 so by now if you understand the
order flow you should see that hey you
know what the stacked imbalance is not
gonna hold and chances are we're gonna
go higher instead of lower because
you're seeing supportive buying in these
bars here at three thousand two thousand
fifteen hundred ten ninety nine you see
in twenty four hundred and then in the
fifth bar I mean that's why we draw
these zones out five and I don't look
for this level to come back five hours
later and say oh yeah you had a stacked
imbalance there at eight fifty I mean
that's I mean that level the
selling that happened here right is now
and to look at it five hours later and
say well you had a stack and balance
there or five hours ago is and entire
take your trade out of it is is just
ludicrous you know it's it's for the
immediate term if you rally back up
there look for the selling that happen
if it doesn't happen then you know it
was you had the initial selling it's not
happening again
chances are the markets gonna go the
other way it's not gonna start selling
off again if you don't get that selling
it you had earlier right and what
happens is boom you start making new
highs
boom boom boom I gotta get very
aggressive buying in here you're seeing
some nice positive deltas you know nice
imbalances 3000 2000 1800 get up here
you start seeing some divergences a nice
negative Delta up here a nice big
selling and balance here but it doesn't
really build on it next bar back up
small negative Delta small Delta's small
Delta and then you start coming in here
alright now this one's not as clear a
sell but it was it was still a
legitimate sell I mean this market at
this point looked like it was ready to
come off again you got your divergence
but you come right back up with a
bullish ratio and then you start seeing
in here the aggressive selling appearing
now this is the information you're gonna
get on a footprint chart that you're not
going to get on a normal bar chart
you're not gonna see this step this
imbalance of 2452
thousand two thousand you not gonna see
that a normal bar chart you know you
need a footprint chart to see that
information but you could take that away
you can see that market is starting to
move lower your scenes very aggressive
selling and selling into these big bids
and the market sells off down into the
64 area you get a bit of a bounce and
you just start going sideways for quite
a while you know like I said later in
the session
we started getting this rally here yeah
the delta scalping give it by delta
scott purcell then boom you got a delta
scalper buy here right before you just
took off you know so you're sort of
spinning your wheels in here with the
signals 1244 long 13:19 short then you
know 1329 long long long is then you get
to pop up you got a ratio and I've
urgent here's the ratio here's your
divergence what happens next bar instead
of being down it's a nutbar
it's a bullish ratio that's not a good
sign that's gonna tell you that it's
probably not gonna work out this short
is not gonna work out again you know
that's what reading the order flow is
you don't have to wait for the to come
up here to stop you out when you see
something like this right when you got
your ratio your divergence that's your
trigger then immediately afterwards you
get something that's bullish in the
opposite direction after you got short
best thing to do is cut your trade don't
don't wait for it to stop you out I mean
you could get out here at you know as a
smaller loss then your full entire loss
so you know you say you're getting short
somewhere here I'll call it twenty four
seventy you could read what's happening
in this bar and get out at twenty four
seventy one as opposed to getting out at
you know twenty four seventy two twenty
four seventy two and a half you know
you're saving yourself a point right
there
then later you know we sold off again
you know after going into the cash
closed a little bit you know right now
in the evening session we're just kind
of going sideways which I expect us to
do until the until the number comes out
later at seven thirty Chicago time now
you know it's just really quick on the
ten range chart and the ESPYs let me
just
find it here really quick tenderness
again you know you had some bearish
signs this morning you didn't quite see
on the on the on a for range this I
found very bearish you had the
divergence you got the ratio on the next
bar a bunch of imbalances and then it
just went sideways unfortunately not
much of a move again that's at 9:30 you
know by 10:30 it's just spinning its
wheels it's an hour into the trade going
nowhere again that's a sign that the
markets just going sideways no point in
letting it come all the way back up here
you know it's stopping you out you're
better you know after an hour if you're
not getting paid on the trade you get
out of the trade there's nothing says
you know you know trades just going
sideways on you for you know an hour to
you got a hold it no you get out you
know knowing one thing the only one a
trade is not working out is you know
half the battle you can appear to this
high again ratio and divergence
divergence rather than the ratio many
imbalances in here a couple imbalances
there and you get salafi and not really
you get you know a couple points you
know before you go into the close but
you know it was something not not the
biggest trade but again you're coming
into month end so you know and and the
cash closed so once the cash closes over
you don't really get much movement on
month end you know the activity is gonna
happen pre cash close no excuse me I
want to talk about a couple markets here
excuse me sorry really quick what was it
I think it was the British Pound and the
euro currency if I could find my charts
okay so the euro currency here we are
now there's quite a few interesting
things here in the euro currency if I
want to talk about this lo here at 8:00
in the morning
8:13 this swing the swing low at the
time right here you got this big volume
in this bar actually and okay so you
know what were you doing just before it
okay you had come up from your your
little earlier at your low for the day
was down here okay seven nineteen what
do you got ratio and divergence now
again you know just so I'm showing you
ratio and divergence go back to you know
whatever or something just okay so you
know at these lows right you got did you
have a divergence and a ratio here no
you got nothing
no ratio you had divergence not a ratio
though next bar no ratio here you got
the ratio and divergence you made a new
low by two ticks and you got a ratio and
divergence again this one is more
interesting you got point of control
right on the bottom of the bar and you
got a nice little move up actually you
know from the 60 area up into you know
up into the 70s then you started coming
back down again and getting down here no
divergence no ratio no divergence no
ratio when I say no ratio every bar has
a ratio whether it's a ratio you like or
you don't like is another story okay
every bar and will have a ratio on the
bottom or on the top its whether it you
know meets your requirement of racial
analysis you know not not all of them do
you know so you're looking for certain
types of ratios so here you got the
ratio and divergence next bar Delta
scalper you know kicking in as well so
you know you see some supportive buying
down here hundred sixty-six one thirty
five point control towards the bottom of
the bar which is also encouraging but
you know this structure right here is
very bullish
and what happens you know we go from the
38 area up into the you know up in here
here maybe you got a real bearish sign
with the imbalance on the top you know
some trapped Raiders up here and tell
her to the top of that bar so you know
that's you know from 38 all the way up
to the 50 areas is decent then you get
down here 8 13 very strong volume 1489
very strong Delta 473 Delta scalper is
giving you this nice by next bar
basically it's just straight up I mean
you see some volume down here on the bid
side and then look at this all 0 so you
know there's very aggressive buying
coming in you pull back in this bar
towards this point of control and you
just keep going higher you know higher
higher higher I mean that was what's
that area 50 you know 11850 you know we
trade up into the into the mid-60s you
know eventually we just keep going
higher higher higher
no major reason really to be you know
cutting this position I mean you know me
you can make an argument up here you
know you got a point of control up near
the top you got the price rejector you
know but even that you know from 50
that's up around the 68 area if we get
an out so that's a nice trade if you're
not you know there's no signs up here
you know this is not just got a bearish
ratio doesn't mean doesn't mean you
guy get out of that position you know
then again you start getting up here you
start seeing some bearish ratios maybe
you might think of getting out if you do
boom you get another Delta scalper
giving you a buy signal here and the
market again shoots up from you know 81
it just keeps going up and up no no
major signs really to be getting out yet
maybe you can make an argument with this
one I won't get into it but you know
these this is very kind of a bearish bar
in the analysis you know so again you
know from what was that level 1 1 1880
was it I don't remember now
where was it was that imbalance yeah
here 118 you know getting along here at
you know that's at 119 already so again
you know there were some nice trades to
be had in the euro currency again you
got another Delta scalper by here and it
just shoots straight
I mean I should pull up a bar chart it
would be a lot easier you know it's foot
than the footprints are just for
visually to see it but again you know
this is this is a nice a nice trade you
know 118 85 86 area all the way up into
the you know 119 s again so you know
you're getting a lot of you know another
Delta scalper by here you know back up
into the new highs and what you got up
here you got ratio and divergence boom
you come back up here you test the high
you don't get stopped out and then you
sell off again again from you know the 1
1913 area you're back down
you know below 1 1:19 you're back into
the one 1880s again Delta scalper gives
you a buy here you got a delta scalper
sell this one doesn't work out the buy
does okay so you know you see all these
trades and you know you get stopped out
here you get stopped out here great it's
not the end of the world you know you've
had a lot of nice straight so you got
divergence there you know later in the
day you got a bias is 250 in the
afternoon
it'll buy here and it rallies back up
and there so you know there was some
very very nice trades to be had you know
in the euro currency you know even if
you're just looking at a plain 5-minute
chart in the euro currency what do you
got you had your buy here at 8:30 you
know again 11850 area all the way up to
119 actually it goes higher like you
know up here you got another buy here
119 area so again that's 50 points in
the euro currency on a 5-minute chart
that's brilliant you know I mean you
just do that once a day and you'd be
happy I'm even gonna be lucky to get it
once a day some days you won't get it
some days you might get you know minus
10 pick some days you might get plus 20
ticks but you know what those days where
you get 50 ticks you know that's that's
what's gonna make your account grow okay
so I really quick I'll talk about crude
oil here crude headed a nice rally today
and you know this this morning you know
today's European session we were
rallying you got a divergence that
failed here divergence that failed he
started selling off here no this was you
know this is hard to explain properly
this is
sort of a order flow pattern that you
see right you hit your high you sell off
a little bit then you come back up you
get the single print you get the bearish
ratio then you sell off again you know
what it's telling you is you know we hit
our high sold off buyers are coming back
in seeing if they can take it higher
you're getting the price rejection I
don't understand how people look at at
normal Candlestick bars and say they're
trading price action you know that's I
don't know it's you know they're not I
guess I guess yeah they're trading price
action I guess the way I described what
order flow is is more volume action and
volume is going to be more important
than price if you treat price the same
all prices as being equal you're way way
off and you're trading analysis you know
it's going to be what's going to be more
important you know whether you trade
zero prices at a level even though you
know on the offer where you trade 61 you
know people that they'll just say well
we traded there you know here we traded
we traded this price period but you and
you look at it and analyze it well yeah
you traded you know nine Lots there
against eighty nine here you got an
imbalance you know that's important
information if you're not using this
information in your trading you're
really you know leaving a lot I mean on
the table you're leaving very important
information no not all prices are equal
and if you treat all prices as being
equal then you know you're gonna you're
gonna suffer you know here right you had
a two Lots traded on the bit here at
forty six I know what this was 46:15 but
you know people just say well yeah you
know they won't even notice that because
they're just in case what we traded
46:15 but when you look at this you know
that this is a very very bullish sign
you know these single prints in the bar
and because the markets moving quickly
so anyway we know we come off the high
price action volume action however you
want to describe it I prefer volume
action of hit better than price action
actually and you rally back up you got
some signs of price rejection here based
on the volume you sell off you come down
into the swing low here at you know
forty six bucks and then the buying just
comes right back in you know at this
point everyone is thinking you know hey
46 bucks is is a good base you know
earlier right we had traded up past
forty six bucks and look at this we
couldn't break back past 46 46
dollars is right here you know we're
hanging around 4605 4607 4608 you make
this move back down in the 46 bucks you
see some very strong buying coming in
here 792 463 353 annex bar look at this
Delta 754 that's massive next bar 696 so
you know over these two bars it's
dominated by a very aggressive mind even
in this bar here where you have the
Delta scalper kicking off I mean look at
this
Maxx Delta 760 so the strongest the
Delta was in the bar was 760 and a close
at 754 so close right almost on its max
Delta number and even this bar here you
know as were selling down into 46 bucks
right he had aggressive selling min
Delta - 412 but what happened the buying
came back and went from minus 4 12 to
plus 90 so that's a swing of almost 500
lots you know from a net aggressive
selling to net aggressive mind and then
you know Delta's cup kicks off it would
pop up here we start going up to new
highs you have a divergence here that's
not necessarily a reason by itself to
sell I hate selling I hate it when
people say we got divergence you got a
sell no you don't you know you need
something else in there besides the
divergence because on a trending day
when the markets trending
you're gonna run into a lot of fail
divergences I don't even know how many
failed divergences are on this move here
but let's let's see what's comp them
let's see if there's any reason to be
getting short at any of these levels
again you got two failed divergence
that's not a reason by itself to fail
boom another failed divergence here boom
you take out the highs you got a nice
stack buying imbalance as you take out
the height up here you got a divergence
no ratio now you're at 47 bucks so
you've just rallied a hundred a hundred
ticks you know you rallied a buck one
from 46 up to 47 no reason to be selling
here get up here no divergence not here
you got divergence and our ratio where
we trade your cranium 47:36 so you got
your first bearish sign up here you got
your
divergence you got your bear
ratio next bar you got the Delta scalper
coming in you got 39 Delta on here I
sorry negative 39 then this bar minus
300 this bar minus 374 this bar minus
266 so you know you got four bars you're
spending you know a lot of negative
Delta I mean earlier you had some bars
here with negative Delta as well then
you came right back up so again you know
maybe you're not convinced that this
mark is gonna sell off but there are
signs already you know because earlier
you had similar signs but slightly
different you know what's missing here
you don't have the divergence you don't
have the ratio you don't have Delta
scalper coming in this is this yellow
thing is another indicator is the
transition so it's transitioning from
what was a demand driven market to a
supply driven market that's what that
means that transition is hard to see
that but what do you got you know so
it's slightly different right it's even
though it looks the same visually you
know you're high you come off a little
bit then you come back up make a new
high you hit your high you come off a
little bit looks like we're starting to
come back
Delta's nuts stronger 303 74 to 66
here's just 290 to 228 138 but you're
seeing the signs in the order flow
already that you didn't see here you
know even though it looks similar it's
not it's different it's much more
negative and what happens you start
going sideways start going sideways
start going sideways then BOOM look at
this Delta minus 630 you had one bar
here positive 194 okay
fair enough it's not the end of the
world you gotta borrow with positive
Delta 630 that's strong negative big
solid imbalance 799 next bar 11 56 so at
this point you should be thinking this
mark is gonna sell off there's nothing
in here telling you this market is gonna
go higher at this point is there right
now no now it does it sell-off yeah it
does it's and it's not the biggest move
it gets back down to below 4700 I think
you know here 47 below so you know is is
it a massive move is it a move like we
just had we just had you know a dollar
move in the crude oil from 46 up all the
way up to the forty sevens you know be
nice to get a move like that on the way
back down but again you can only get
you can only trade what the markets
gonna give you and it's not giving you a
monster move but it's giving you a
decent move you know from 47:25 all the
way back down to you know the 47 24
I'm sorry 47 even area and you know just
sort of go sideways you know here over
the next over a while we come back down
test 47 bucks again you know here we get
below 47 and then you just start working
your way back up you know on the swing
low nothing really here telling you to
buy but you know the fact that we're
starting to come back up you know at 47
10 if you're trailing your stop you know
maybe you're getting out around 47 or
five forty seven ten who knows so it
wasn't you know the big move back down
that he had you know on the back of the
big move back up big move back up was
was a nice move if you if you were on
board for that and you know you could
have got something on that move off that
high as well you know just really quick
just to make it a little easier to see
this is what it looked like on the on
the normal bar chart you know here's
your dollar move up from you know 46 I
don't know what that is 46 15 all the
way up to 47 20 and then you know from
47 this is just the Delta scalper for 47
20 back down you know somewhere in here
maybe 47 10 if you cover it in here I'm
you had you know by here just before the
close though
and then we're a little bit lower in the
evening session okay so you see if
there's any other interesting charts to
show you I don't know there there's
again you know people always ask can it
work within the Delta scope or work with
the Uni Renko chart yes it can you know
here you had one signal in the espys
wasn't the biggest move down but it was
a nice little trade there to be had let
me see if I got any other yeah the
markets that gave some decency let's
take a look at Nasdaq I say I was I
looked at Nasdaq earlier but I'm kind of
curious to see how it ended up for the
day have been like in the Nasdaq a lot
lately
[Music]
where are you and Barry with me here you
know I I just recorded these things
you're on the fly I don't edit them and
look for look for only the good trades
to show you I tried to show you
everything you know I mean that's what
you need to see you don't need to see
only only the trades that work out you
know you need to see when when they're
not working out as well I mean I wish
every trade would work out but again yo
Nasdaq is a market I think is best rated
once the cash opens but you know you
mean it you know this one here was 5:00
in the morning
got a little buy here the cell doesn't
work out then you get you know after the
cash open you get this nice move here I
don't know what is that is you know 49
48 up into the 60 area a couple sells
comfo weak sells this buy works out a
little bit again you know you should be
trading with a stop trailing your stop
you know so at least you get something
out of these trades here like this this
this one you wouldn't got anything out
you get something out of that trade yeah
this one probably nothing place to
stopped out this one you could have got
something out of boom you know here up
down back up again again you know are
these monster moves no you know it's
from ones that 80 up to you know the 86
area then again from the 85 area you
know up in here maybe did a 92 so you
know what's going back and forth I mean
you're getting some opportunities right
that's that's what you want as a trader
it's not like every trade you're gonna
do is gonna be a home run you know it's
like baseball you know you're gonna hit
you know how many home runs gonna play
our hit in a year not hot not many you
know gonna get a lot more singles and
then doubles and triples and you know
gonna get strikeouts so you know not
every trade is gonna be a big home run
like here you get a nice little trade
here know what is this euro currency you
know boom you get a decent trade here
this one doesn't really work out this
one's a nice trade again that doesn't
work out then you get a nice trade here
nice little trade here a small trade
here get a
really nice trade here you know from 75
up to 119 even we get the sell at 119
even comes off again trailing your stop
you know you getting you're getting
short at 119 even you know you getting
stopped out at 118 85 you can say you
get some signals in here this one fails
this one small one maybe fails again
another nice move up here a couple fails
so that's what it's about right
don't don't think you know every trade
you're gonna have is going to be a
monster trade with you know you know a
hundred ticks or whatever I mean yeah
that would be nice but you know not
everyone is going to do it again you
know this is really quick this is the
transition Balto's transition and what
is doing this 100 tick mini Dow you see
here the Reds the sell the blue is the
buy you know so you get stopped out here
but you know you're getting some nice
trees still you getting some nice trades
yeah you get stopped out you know you
lose five ticks what if you do but you
know what you're getting you know 30
ticks you know 20 ticks on some of your
winning trades which is you know what
you want to do everyone this talks about
the risk risk to reward ratio so you got
to have you know even if you have a risk
reward ratio of three to one you know
you're not gonna don't expect 50%
winners you know if you have 10 to 1
don't expect you know 30% winners you
know if you're a risk reward ratio of 10
to 1 and you're getting you know 20%
winners that's fantastic
you know I know a lot of traders they'll
play those odds all day long Nasdaq all
right this is 233 ticket rate 233 tick
chart again you know trade fails so you
got one loser 2 losers 3 losers for
losers okay so what are you losing maybe
you know maybe you're getting this one
you shouldn't take because you let the
market take you in but if you did you
know say you know you're losing a point
we'll call 2 points so 1 2 3 4 you just
lost 8 6 8 points okay now you're
getting along here again you got another
by signaling you're getting along at 66
and was it do it trades all the way up
to you know up there I know that is 80
82 you know so 60 excuse me 60
- 82 is what 16 so you just you know you
lost two ticks here two four six eight
you lost eight ticks you know one two
three four but you just got sixteen back
you know that that's what that's what
people talk about risk to reward ratio
that's what they mean you know hey cure
you know again you know you're getting
short at 96 and you're covering back
down here at 90 you know again you're
getting along at you know 91 you know up
to 96 again so that that's you know
that's three to one risk reward minimum
you know I just on these trades so
there's again you know it's you got to
understand you're rich to reward and
don't expect you know every trade to be
a winner that's what kills me and I get
people complaining oh you know the Delta
scalper it's you know it's kind of
losers well of course every no matter
how you trade you're gonna have losers
and there's no 100% trading system
everybody likes to win right people are
competitive by nature you know if since
you're a little kid right you play
sports everyone talks about you gotta
win place when I grew up that's how is
now it's like all you just participated
that's great but you know in training
participating you know you can lose all
your money and it's not like oh thanks
for playing here's the trophy no it's
not you know your score is kept by you
know the balance in your trading account
not oh you traded and that's good enough
no it's not you know if people trade
because they want to make money they
want to win and so there's a winning
mentality but you know people don't like
to lose and when you're trading with the
risk to reward ratio of say 5 to 1 you
know you're happy to get you know 25%
winners you know 4 to 1 winners or 1
winner - every for losers you know that
that's how it looks at but people don't
understand that they you know everyone
talks about risk reward but then you
know no one wants to lose and you know I
understand that and I hate to lose but
you know losing trains happen but if you
have a good about the risk to reward
ratio a high one you're gonna have a lot
of little losers you know cut your
winners short let your winners cut your
loser short let your winners right
that's what trading is about isn't it so
anyway
I'm starting to babble um you know I end
up going long on this one in a 30-minute
video again I try to keep these a little
bit shorter 15 minutes but sometimes you
know I just get excited you know people
think I'm drinking my own kool-aid so to
speak but they learn more about order
flows go to order flows calm learn more
about the Delta scalper go to Delta
scalper calm and again you know if you
haven't subscribed to this channel
please subscribe and I've got you know
I'm working on a new project actually
about trading deals with the mental side
of trading you know I traders fail I
trader succeed you know things like
setting goals and all that stuff and
that's why sometimes you don't see me
doing a video if again if I just don't
have time for everything I wish I did
but you know when you got three kids
three kids below the age of five your
your hands are pretty tied up so anyway
guys I'm just going on about nonsense
now so have a good day and enjoy the the
Labor Day weekend it's a long weekend so
I'll catch you guys next week most
likely bye bye